wow this is so fun i feel rich
don't spill evelyn don't spill this one
genius if i do say so myself it's only
stupid if it doesn't work
[Music]
hello i'm alvin welcome back to tasty's
making big the show where i make giant
versions of some of america's most
beloved foods so today i'm going to be
making a huge chocolate chip cookie
let's get started
okay so uh the first thing to making
great cookies is a lot of butter as you
can see this is 10 sticks of butter so
this recipe is a scaled version of one
of my older tasty recipes of cookies and
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna brown the
butter
one
two eight nine ten okay and this is
going to take a while to melt down if
you'll excuse me i'm gonna melt this
butter for a little bit wow this is so
fun i feel rich
oh some of the little flavored brown
bits are starting to come up to the
surface that's a good sign okay so i've
turned off the heat and i think this is
beautiful it's like liquid gold okay so
this guy is going to go off the heat and
it's time to make the rest of the dough
so now it's time to make the dough i
found the largest bowl that we could
find in the tasty kitchen and
yeah let's make some cookies first i
have a lot of brown sugar a lot of white
sugar for a lot of flavor i like to add
a lot of salt let's just give this a mix
break up all that brown sugar so this
recipe is 10 times the size of the
normal batch of cookie dough which makes
about like 12 cookies so this is gonna
be one very very large cookie okay oh
the wrong way
now that it's cooled off a bit my
favorite part
brown butter
[Music]
smells ridiculous and back in look at
that
one of the biggest reasons why i really
like baking cookies it's literally
because of this part where i get to
smell the brown butter and the sugar
there's a candle that smells like this i
would spend a lot of money a lot of eggs
and quite a lot of vanilla extract here
we go
coming together it's gonna work out you
know
all right the texture we want is these
beautiful silky
gold ribbons time for the dry
ingredients 10 cups of flour
a lot of baking soda and back in we go
slow this time don't spill alvin don't
spill this one just do one of these yeah
that'll mix it in real good genius if i
do say so myself it's only stupid if it
doesn't work this mixer really does have
a mind of its own okay
i think
the dough part is ready but can't have
chocolate chip cookies without the
chocolate so i'm gonna go get lots and
lots of chocolate
be right back
okay so i brought a lot of chocolate i
like to use both milk and dark chocolate
i'll start with the milk chocolate first
i'm going to chop these all up into
pretty large chunks
oh yeah
that's what i'm talking about let's get
all this into the batter let's just
start cutting some dark chocolate
that's so satisfying wow
this is like 20 chocolate bars i believe
all right i'm saving these two bars for
decoration so i'm going to mix this
wonderful
chocolate into the dough probably one of
my favorite parts it's like like mixing
a salad oh yeah
listen to that sound
you know what i'm gonna use my hands
oh this feels so nice okay i think
that's mixed time to figure out how i'm
gonna bake this guy let me go check in
the back to see what we have
okay i found this uh really big cake pan
that we have in the tasty kitchen i
think this will be a perfect size got
some parchment strips to keep it
non-stick just spray it just to be sure
parchment sling
technique go in there have it in the
pattern almost like a clock okay i think
this pan is sufficiently lined now the
gotta get all this batter out of there
come on
whoa nice all right let's get the rest
of you
i'm gonna spread this out
i'm gonna use my hands let's get you
situated just in case we didn't have
enough chocolate we're gonna put some
more chocolate i'll go here you know is
there really such thing as too much
chocolate i don't think so two entire
bars of chocolate just for the topping
this guy is ready for the oven i am so
happy with what we have right now oh we
let's put you in the oven big guy ah
there's this is cookies like
at least 50
chocolate which is a good thing because
when i make cookies i get to control how
much chocolate goes in
all right let's bake you for
probably like an hour to
300 nice and low to give the whole thing
enough time to cook
wow
later dude
oh boy this is
this is a heavy one
wow so this is what the cookie looks
like after
one and a half hours of baking and a lot
of resting time so i could slowly cool
down i'm really proud of this and you
know you can't have a giant cookie
without big milk i'm also very excited
because i have a friend named lindsay
who's baked cookies and really likes
making cookies so i think it'd be really
fun face timer in to see what she thinks
of this let's get lindsay on the phone
what's up lindsay hi
how's it going good i'm mad i'm not
there to eat whatever you're making i
would have preferred if there are other
people to share it with lindsay made a
really cool video where she challenged a
lot of tasty producers to bake things
and that was a really fun one because
you've made so many things that video
and lindsay also happened to make my
cookies which was really fun i actually
baked your cookies a lot for jasmine
because she's obsessed with them all
right well do you want to see it i'm
ready ready one
two three
alvin is a cake
and all the milk you made it so
beautiful thanks it's a 16 inch cake pan
the largest we could find at the store
this is a vase i think i guess that's
the next step for me i guess it's just
to go bigger that's right go big or go
home that's the motto of the show all
right well thanks lindsay i'll see you
soon all right good luck all right bye
so it happens to be almost christmas and
milk and cookies are a family tradition
at least for me around that time i leave
them out for santa so i thought it would
be fun to see if we can tempt santa
claus to come in hopefully we get some
never before seen footage of the ever
elusive santa claus
merry christmas oh
what is this it seems to be a large
cookie
and milk usually when kids leave it out
for me it's not this big whoever made
this must be a fine lad i will bring him
many presents
no one seems to be watching i see no
reason not to try my oh my this is quite
the large
cookie look at this texture there's so
much chocolate and cookie i think i will
have myself a bite usually everybody
says where is santa but no one asks how
is santa the biggest problem of having
this beard is that i hard to put food in
my mouth hole
hold your crumbs in my beard hmm
freeze rudolph this is a good cookie
this may be the best cookie i've had in
all my years i think i shall take this
cookie and hightail it back to the north
pole
oh sweet sugar plum i'm out of here
[Music]